-Our next guest is an Emmy and
Golden Globe-nominated actress
and producer you know from
her work on films like
"Mank" and "Rules Don't Apply."
She stars in the third season of
"Emily in Paris," which begins
streaming on Netflix
December 21st.
Let's take a look.
-Bonjour, it's Emily in Paris.
Today is day one of
funemployment.
I want to know where and what
you guys want to see.
I am your eyes and ears
to this beautiful city.
Wow, oh. A lot of you are
joining already.
Okay, let's see here.
"I want to see Monet's
'Water Lilies.'" So do I.
"Can you try Angelina's
hot chocolate?
I do not need an excuse
for that, so yes, I will.
And "Go back to --
go back to America."
No, I think we're done here
for now, alright?
But my DMs are open and I will
see you there, mwah, merci!
-Please welcome back to the show
Lily Collins, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am so happy to have you here.
-I am so happy to be back.
-This is very exciting.
We did not know this, and I will
admit to have not seen the film,
but you and Paul Bettany worked
together before.
-We did. It was my second film,
yeah, called "Priest."
-Called "Priest."
It was described on Google
as a sci-fi vampire thriller.
Is that --
-I mean, that feels very
appropriate for about
eight years ago.
They were very in at the time.
-It was a lot of vampire stuff.
-There was a lot of
vampire stuff.
-And here is a real good shot.
Obviously this is a very sort of
heady, dialogue-driven --
-Yes, very.
-Chamber piece,
and here's a picture of you
and Paul. There you are.
-And look, that's --
that face says it all.
I mean, I think this was
like my third day on set.
-Well, there you go.
-Yeah.
-Very natural. You definitely
seem to be concerned.
-Flailing, I like to say.
-A lot has happened since you
were last year.
Engaged, married, celebrated
your one-year anniversary,
congratulations.
-Thank you.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, a lot happened in COVID.
-A lot happened in COVID.
One of the nice things about
sort of being in
this side of it, especially with
"Emily in Paris,"
this is a show people enjoyed
a great deal during COVID.
But we were talking backstage,
this is the first time you've
actually been able to be out
and promoting it
and see your cast off the set.
-Yeah. It's crazy.
Also to be back in rooms like
this with an audience,
with you, it's so nice.
We never really got to celebrate
together,
and all of a sudden
it feels real.
You know when something
comes out
and all you're seeing is
stats and numbers.
And you're like,
"I think it's hitting?
I don't know,
I think people like it?"
Now you get to have the
interactions
and celebrate
and it feels really special.
-It is really special, and it's
really cool to have it back on.
You have a costar in the show,
Bruno,
who is also one of the stars of
"White Lotus."
-I know!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was very nice to see him
turn up in both.
Have you caught up
on "White Lotus"?
-I have not yet caught up.
Unfortunately,
I haven't had time.
You know, World Cup
has also been on.
I'm so sorry to say,
but it's been like
"Emily" press and World Cup.
But I'm very excited
to support Bruno,
and I loved season one,
so I'm very excited.
-Well, I won't give anything
away.
It turns out great for him.
[ Laughter ]
-I've heard little spoilers
already.
-Wait, World Cup now,
I know we're down to
France and Argentina.
Is "Emily in Paris" loyalty here
making you root for France?
-I mean, we were just in Paris
promoting a show
and there was a game, and all of
us running from room to room
in our PJs, being like,
"The game's on!"
They're like, "We got to get
ready for the premiere!"
And everyone's like,
"What do we choose?"
But it's been really fun
to support and cheer on.
Charlie and I both love watching
it. It's so fun.
-I've been lucky enough to know
your husband over the years.
I also know his parents.
You have very good in-laws.
I'm lucky. I have good in-laws
as well.
Is this is something that you
recognized early on,
that you hit the jackpot?
-Yeah.
Oh, my God, are you kidding?
Mary, Ted, Malcolm -- I'm so
fortunate for my in-laws.
I think I actually met Mary
and Ted before I met Charlie,
which was interesting.
We danced together.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-This is Ted Danson
and Mary Steenburgen.
You got to work with Ted
on an episode of "Curb."
-I did.
-More importantly, you got to
work with Larry --
I mean, Ted's great, I love Ted.
But you got to do a scene with
Larry David.
-Yeah, it was like a fleeting
10 to 20 seconds where we just
freaked out at each other,
which was so fun.
We just like screamed
at each other.
-You did.
I went back and watched.
If memory served, when I was
thinking about it today,
I don't think it's very long
that they spent together.
But you got the full Larry.
-Guys.
-[ Laughter ]
That is the most important
freeze frame
you'll ever see of me.
I think that that's the most --
I mean, it literally was just
like "aaaah" the whole time.
And it was all improv.
I guess I can "aaaah" improv
really well, I don't know.
-You can scream improv.
-I scream with Paul
flying off a train
and I can do it with Larry.
-They saw "Priest"
and they were like,
"I think if she's as good
as she was there."
[ Laughter ]
-Same outfit too.
-How do you find out
that you're going to be
in an episode of "Curb"?
Do you just get a phone call?
-Yeah, actually, weirdly I was
up shooting "Windfall,"
a movie I did with Charlie,
and it was my 32nd birthday.
I got a phone call saying that
Larry David wants you in "Curb."
And I was like, "Why?
Why me? What?"
I had known his daughter Cazzie
for a while,
and I assumed it was that,
and it was like,
no, they have a storyline about
you and "Emily in Paris."
I just thought
that was so random.
And amazing because
I'm a huge fan.
And yeah, it was
kind of surreal.
And I found out -- It was weird,
actually.
I found out on my 30th birthday
that I was going to be
in "Emily in Paris."
And then on my 32nd birthday,
I found out I was going to be
in "Curb."
On my 20th birthday I found out
I'd be in my first movie,
"The Blind Side." I'm like,
what's going to happen at 40?
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's going to be
"Priest 2" with Paul Bettany.
-Yes!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I am down. I am down.
-So your costar, Ashley Park,
you guys actually live,
basically, in the same building
in Paris
where you're shooting the show.
-We did. This is the first year
that we lived in
the same building,
which was so much fun.
It was basically
life imitating art.
And every day we'd either, like,
run up to each other's
apartments, we'd, like, do lines
together -- Whoa, whoa.
[ Laughter ]
We would run lines together.
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We call it "run lines."
-Yeah, okay.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Correction.
We, like, played Mario Kart
together.
We'd talk about life.
And we'd go on adventures around
the city, scootering, bicycling.
-This is like a photo
from a mystery novel.
Because this is a photo that...
-Oh, my God.
-...was taken by Ashley
at a flea market.
And there's something that's
happening in this moment.
-No one here will ever know.
But I will tell you.
Okay, so we're at a flea market.
And this is a selfie that Ashley
took in a mirror, which --
It's very telling of all three
of us in this photo.
Ashley loves to, you know, take
photos wherever we go to,
like, create memories
and have it.
Charlie is being inquisitive,
as one should,
talking to the artist
where we are.
And I'm feverishly
touching my tooth,
realizing I just chipped
my entire front tooth
and I have to film a close-up
on Monday, and it's Saturday.
And we're in France, where
things are...a lot of the time.
And finding a dentist
on a Sunday
would be nearly impossible.
But per Emily's solution-driven
nature, I found a dentist.
-Wow.
-On a Sunday morning who had
been out the night before
at the Rolling Stones concert.
[ Laughter ]
And bicycled to the office, let
me in, didn't really scrub up,
then I lay on the table and he's
like, "Let me fix your tooth."
I was like, "Okay!"
And he did a great job,
and he didn't charge me.
-Wow.
-I was a win-win.
-That's a real "Emily in Paris"
storyline.
Do you remember
how you chipped it?
-I was eating an apple
in the back of a taxi.
-Une pomme?
-Une pomme. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Une pomme which I will never,
ever do again.
-Pas du pomme.
No, not good.
-My mom was a French teacher,
so that's why.
-It's very impressive.
-Comes pretty naturally to me.
[ Laughter ]
-There is something that
happened,
I guess in your writers room,
that happens on the show
this year, which is a pigeon
gets in the office.
-Yeah, I mean, has that never
happened to you?
-It has happened to us.
We had a pigeon in our office.
-Oh, really? Oh, my God!
-We have pigeons in our office
like pretty much all the time.
-I mean, we're in New York.
I get it.
-We are in New York.
-I get it.
-Did you get to actually work
with them?
-We did.
-Professional pigeons?
-Guys, pigeons are
some of the hardest cast
to wrangle and they're
the most expensive.
-Really? The pigeons cost more
than on other actors?
-They come with wranglers.
-Okay.
-And there are multiple
kinds of pigeons.
There are the trained
flight pigeons
and there are the wild pigeons.
And in this, in episode 3, you
see we get to deal with both.
-Really?
-We had a clear flight plan
for these pigeons to go through.
-Uh-huh.
-And they just didn't.
And what they used in the show
was real-life moments of them
going rogue.
-I feel like you definitely want
to throw in
the extra couple of euros to get
the trained pigeons
as opposed to the wild pigeons.
-I know. One would think.
But they were landing
all over the place.
They didn't speak French.
They didn't speak English.
They didn't speak pigeon.
They just, like, did
their own thing.
And all the takes that they used
are of Kate Walsh and I trying
our hardest not to crack a smile
or laugh
and just screaming at them
in whatever language we could.
-Yeah.
-To get them to move.
-This seems very similar to
your work with Larry David.
You just had to scream.
-[ Laughter ]
-I'm so good at that.
I just -- Yeah.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on season three.
-Thank you.
-We're always so happy
when you stop by.
-I love being here.
-You guys, Lily Collins.
The third season of
"Emily in Paris"
begins streaming December 31st
on Netflix.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."